et maintenant quoi ma gueule qu'elle a
ma gueule voici joey starr
quand les stars bonsoir d'être ici pour
la sortie d'un single qui s'appelle
gazelle et qui figure sur la bande son
du film astérix et obélix mission
cléopâtre d'alain chabat
vous savez comment fait que petit ma job
pour faire croire à un parcours montre
les pas fait alors part expliqué zhou et
en même temps une bague et nantes
qu'elle fonde un gros pendant ta gueule
qu'est ce que tu veux mon grand
ce gaz est extrait de la bande originale
du film d'alain chabat astérix et obélix
mission cléopâtre alors alain chabat est
un vrai fan de vous en l'an 2000 avait
fait un documentaire s'appelait
authentique réalisé par lui et sa r6
chauffeur
ouais d'ailleurs vous deviez jouer dans
le film astérix vous deviez jouer le
rôle de nick la police mais vous a fait
vous êtes disparu du scénario à la
quatrième version pourquoi vous étiez en
taule au moment du tournage n'ont même
pas alors même pas alors il y a un an
sortait une compilation des remixes de
ntm
c'était un vrai carton ça c'est
énormément vendu est aujourd'hui un
thème est un peu en stand by nom et
émeutes où l'ours machine et qu'à chaque
fois qu'on part pour faire une tournée
vous faire un six mois de promo à
répéter trois mois avant fin rapide à un
truc car chaque conte l'entrée en phase
avec la tm j'en prenais toujours si
salinois de préparation ou autre et ça
nous permettait pas de faire ce qu'on
avait envie de faire à côté quoi bon
s'est dit tiens on va essayer quand on
voit alors vous avez quand même vendu 2
millions de disques avec ntm et ça fait
quatre ans qui a rien de frais qui est
sorti est ce que est ce que c'est pour
toujours ou vous pensez re bosser avec
kool shen ntm on met toujours crois qu'à
3 faire l'album en fait c'est dans les
traits alors aujourd'hui mille façons en
fait même si ça prend 1,64 ouais
aujourd'hui vous vivez à saint-ouen dans
une communauté hip hop dans un pavillon
il ya tout votre bande hip hop non ouais
nous on n'est pas des beatniks on en
vient aux collectivités mais bon une
communauté alors vous dites certaines
nuits on se retrouve à 50 alors ses
lauriers votre studio un enregistrement
et puis aussi vous faites votre émission
pour skyrock
je dis ça s'appelle jeudi jour de ces
demies et le samedi s'appellent
métaphore malabry ça vous emmerde d'être
devenu un des uns des personnages comme
ça des français vit dans un monde h
intrasèque donc sur ma terrasse très
pourquoi ouais mais bon je me suis dit
quoi ouais vous êtes médiatique
maintenant ouais je crois